céline est un cas à part cette
orthophoniste de 48 ans n'a pas pu
reprendre le travail ce vendredi
et pour cause elle n'est toujours pas
vaccinées contre le coc vie de 19 céline
n'est pas une anti vaccins convaincue
elle ne défilent pas les samedis de
mobilisation non c'est une contre
indication médicale qui l'en empêche
j'ai rencontré plusieurs médecins qui se
sont opposés à la vaccination de la
première cause étant une banale la
première contre indication médicale
étant une tumeur artério-veineuse qui a
une seule émet des doutes quant à la
vaccination depuis près de deux mois
céline jongle donc entre la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie et la haute
autorité de santé aujourd'hui elle est
plongée dans une impasse administrative
le problème étant que je ne rendent pas
forcément dans toutes les cases de la
contre-indication vaccinale notamment
une qui demande encore à être étudiés
compréhensive cette mère de quatre
enfants est pourtant prête à toutes les
concessions pour reprendre son activité
professionnelle et attester sur
l'honneur mais difficultés les problèmes
de santé je m'engage et je m'engage à
poursuivre mon activité professionnelle
en conservant les gestes barrière en
faisant tester tous les trois jours s'il
le faut là n'est pas le souci c'est à
dire que j'aimerais avoir une
reconnaissance de cette difficulté de
santé qui ne rentrent pas en fait dans
les cases delà de la sphère faille je
peux comprendre que pour eux ce soir une
situation inédite ce lundi tôt dans la
matinée la cpam lui a accordé un sursis
de deux mois deux mois pendant lesquels
elle pourra continuer d'exercer mais
passé ce délai elle devra toujours
fournir des preuves de sa
contre-indication vaccinale une solution
qui ne la satisfait pas céline a donc
entamé une grève de la faim devant le
siège de l'organisme de santé publique
soutenu par son groupe d'amis plus que
jamais déterminé à retrouver son cabinet